The Vertebra.
Adaptive immune system is one of the
most complex and most beautiful pieces of
biological architecture that
we know of and its complexity.
Its precision and its power indicate
a long history of coevolution with
pathogens.
The adaptive immune system is slower
and more precise than the innate immune
system and it has the capacity for memory.
The vertebrate immune system
is of a type discussed here,
found only invertebrates but
it also exists is analogs
in some invertebrates and
vertebrates at evolved at least twice.
Once in jawless fish,
lampreys and hagfish and then in the
jaw of vertebrates the two systems share
some design features but they originated
independently in George vertebrates.
The key event was incorporating
a transposable genetic
element of carried two
genes,
rag one and rag two.
Those two genes carry the machinery
that enables the somatic recombination,
the generates antibody and
t cell receptor diversity.
Yeah.
Does that diversity that gives the
system is flexibility to recognize a huge
range of molecules, pathogens that
have never been encountered before,
but also microbial self,
self nor microbial
nonself and food antigens.
This would be one of the reasons
that we react to food allergies.
The specificities of the antigen
receptors are those not genetically
predetermined?
The receptors are assembled from
fragments of gene products by somatic
recombination mediated by rag genes.
Okay.
The major histocompatibility complex
produces molecules of two types,
class one and class two.
They first evolved in cartilaginous fish,
both present fragments of proteins on
cell surfaces for recognition by t cell
receptors, so they're part of
the presentation mechanism.
MHC class one molecules occur in all
nucleated cells or they present viral
proteins during intracellular infections.
Class two molecules
occur in dendritic cells,
macrophages and B cells,
and these are the cells that present
antigenic peptides from extracellular
sources such as those from
phagocytosed bacteria.
Okay.
MHC class one and two genes are highly
polymorphic with many illegals that are
circulating in the human population.
These jeans are code dominant.
That means each or Lele is contributing
to the pool of peptides that combine to
form.
Yeah.
In an outbred population.
Most individuals are
heterozygous for most MHC genes,
so most of us are carrying a huge
library of variants that can be brought
together in different combinations,
astronomically large number of
combinations to deal with a huge array of
proteins that are coming in from
pathogens and other sources.
Yeah.
In terms of tissues and organs,
the lymphocytes arise from
stem cells in bone marrow.
So much of that is produced in the large
bones of the leg in the hip and the t
lymphocytes mature in the Thymus,
which is at the base of the throat
and the B lymphocytes in bone marrow,
they migrate to lymph
nodes, spleen, tonsils,
appendix and payer's
patches for processing.
So you should think of your immune system
is having being distributed all over
the body,
but having a particular network
that is the focus of action.
They are activated by antigen in these
organs and they circulate between blood,
lymph and those other Oregon's until
they encounter their specific antigens.
So they are continually
circulating through the body.
You're on patrol.
Okay.
When hematopoietic stem
cells leave the bone marrow,
they either differentiate into lymphoid
progenitors and those migrate to the
Thymus.
Those would be t cells or
they differentiate into
myeloid progenitors that
become monocytes migrate to tissues
where they differentiate into immature or
myeloid cells such as dendritic
cells and macrophages.
So this diverse population of immune
cells is actually all coming out of the
same stem cell progenitor
population and the bone marrow.
Okay.
When immature dendritic cells in
counter and antigen, the internalize it,
digest it, take fragments of it,
put them onto their cell surface,
migrate to lymph nodes, and they're,
they activate so-called naive t cells,
t cells that have not
yet been put into action.
Okay.
During migration, the dendritic
cells mature during that period,
they lose their ability
to engulf pathogens.
That means that they're only going to
be expressing one kind of pathogen when
they encounter that t cell
and they develop an increased
ability to communicate
with t cells.
So they come in to the lymph node,
able to deliver one clear signal.
Okay.
Cytotoxic t cells that are activated by
their druidic cells then undergo rapid
clonal expansion and
migrate throughout the body.
In search of cells
exhibiting corresponding
t cells kill cells.
They do it either by secreting
Porphyrin or similar substances,
the damage the cell membrane and
cause the cell to swell and lice.
Or they give it a signal of apoptosis,
which causes the target silver shrink
and die. They tell it to commit suicide.
Hematopoietic stem cells that do not
migrate to the thymus and mature in the
bone marrow yield the antigen
specific precursors of B cells.
The B cell precursors migrate
to [inaudible] secondary
lymphoid organs such as
lymph nodes and spleen.
And when the B cell
receptors recognize antigens,
then B lymphocytes activate and
undergo rapid clonal expansion,
gaining increased ability to recognize
foreign antigens being lymphocytes
recognize and present antigens and
they function in immune memory.
Okay,
so here's the menagerie of
cells in the immune system.
They all start with a plurry
potent metapod stem cell.
They can produce the lymphoid progenitor
a mile or a myeloid progenitor or a
mega carrier site or an arrhythmia blast.
So our red blood cells are also
coming from the same source.
The macrophage progenitors can produce
neutrophils, eosinophils, basophils,
and monocytes.
And the lymphoid progenitors
are producing B cells, t cells,
and natural killer cells as well
as immature dendritic cells.
So those are the main players in terms
of cell types in the adaptive immune
system.
Okay.
So the B cells secrete antibodies.
The t cells have several functions.
The natural killer and k cells can kill
virus infected cells before they burst.
Yeah.
The,
among the myeloid cells,
the macrophages eat bacteria and
activate bacterial killing mechanisms.
They present antigens.
The dendritic cells take up antigen and
tissue and presented in lymph nodes.
The others released signals from their
granules when they're activated during
the adaptive immune response,
eosinophils kill large antibody coated
multicellular parasites and mass cells
trigger inflammatory
responses and tissues.
So they have specialized functions
and they coordinate their responses by
talking to each other.
The adaptive immune system is activated
by the innate immune system and it
relies upon it to know what type
of pathogen is responding to
it's key features or somatic generation
of diverse antigen receptors.
And then clonal selection of cells
with receptors that match pathogen
antibodies.
Okay.
The adaptive immune system,
this operates using the
principle of natural selection.
It selects clones to respond
to specific antigen signals.